Right. When I got to Hollywood, uh I I I
I kind of learned very quickly like it's
it's about getting around who you know,
right? And um there was a a gym called
Crunch Fitness that was right up above
Sunset and just at the beginning of the
Sunset Boulevard and I got a job there
and there's a lot of celebrities that
worked there. So you've met Eminem there
and met Eminem, Britney Spears, Justin
Timberlake, all these guys used to work
out there and and and I remember hearing
about these parties. I never got invited
to one of those parties or I never ended
up at one of them, but um from the looks
of it, it seemed like that was a good
thing. What What do people say about it,
the parties? Just that it's crazy. They
they would talk about the drug infueled,
you know, like just things get out of
control and there's people walking
around with platters of whatever drugs
you want to take. I mean, that was Yeah,
just it's just a different lifestyle
that these people are living. All right.
So, Diddy obviously getting in the news
a lot lately because of this very
high-profile um court case. The trial
has just begun. Yeah. And and you know,
we get a lot of questions in this area
and I think I think it's good to be
reminded there is some terrible things
that happen in Hollywood. Mhm. I
interact with a lot of kids when we go
and we talk about this subject and
sometimes they maybe have a glamorized
view of Hollywood and want to go there
for a living or or you know use their
creative talents somehow to get to
Hollywood and and work in this industry.
And this is a word of caution I think to
any parent to any child or anybody
that's like you know thinking about
doing this as a career. This is this is
this is a peak and a window into what
some of these people, not everybody, but
some of these people have to experience
to get to this level of fame. What do
you guys know about this trial? Um I
mean it was it went pretty viral. Yeah.
What was it like eight months ago or
something? But yeah, it's it's it was
quite shocking when I found out about
it. Shocking and not shocking. shocking
because it was just so severe
accusations and so intense and not so
shocking because it's Hollywood. I mean,
yeah, you kind of accept it because
you're like, okay, they're all and they
have all grown up with this thing called
fame and it's like, yeah, but the more
you dig into it, the worse it gets.
Yeah, I think that's the most shocking
part is like it seems like there's no
end to where like this whole trial or
the whole like the list of things that
he seemingly like has done. Yeah. I
mean, this is a terrible terrible thing
that that that anybody that was involved
in his world had to experience. I mean,
there the abuse is on a completely
different level. It's even hard to hear
about it and to talk about it, but
that's not really the purpose of of why
we're bringing this up right here. Um, I
find it interesting that he's wearing a
big old diamond cross.
Yeah, that's what a lot of these R&B
artists, hip-hop artists do. I don't
know. It's like their style or
something. It's trendy. It's It calls
attention. I don't know. Everyone does
it. everyone does it, you know, and and
these guys are rubbing shoulders with
some very very dark entities. So, I I
don't think that that cross means the
same thing to them as it probably does
to the Christian, right? And I also
think it's quite, you know, we've talked
about on this channel before like like
making a diamondstudded cross is kind of
blasphemous. Mhm. You know, that was a
that was an instrument of torture that
our God endured for us to have the
opportunity to to be reconciled with
God. And so, you know, to make it a
fashion statement, I think is a bit of a
slam into that what that symbolizes.
Mhm. It looks like she's wearing one,
too. And it looks like he has one in his
ear. Yeah. Yeah. you know, and and I'm
sure like if if you're following this
case, you know, you're going to hear
some things that come out of there that
that are just downright weird and
twisted. I mean, the whole description
of some of the things that are done in
their his famous freakoff parties is I
would not want to be on the jury. No.
Yeah. They have to watch. I mean,
there's video footage of this kind of
stuff. I mean, so you were in Hollywood
for 10 years. I was. And and you
actually heard our new people who went
to the freakoff parties, right? I did. I
did um right when I got to Hollywood uh
I I I kind of learned very quickly like
it's it's about getting around who you
know, right? It's not really necessarily
like how good you are at that thing yet.
It's sort of how who you know that
you're going to get into what doors. And
um there was a a gym called Crunch
Fitness that was right up above Sunset
and just at the beginning of the Sunset
Boulevard and I got a job there and
there's a lot of celebrities that worked
there. So, you've met Eminem there and
met Eminem, Britney Spears, Justin
Timberlake, all these guys who used to
work out there and and and I remember
hearing about these parties cuz this all
happened. I was there in 1999 all the
way to about
2009 and um this stuff transpired during
the times that I was out there. I never
got invited to one of those parties or I
never ended up at one of them, but um
from the looks of it, it seemed like
that was a good thing. What what do
people say about it the parties and
stuff? Just that it's crazy. They they
would talk about the drug infueueled,
you know, like just things get out of
control and there's people walking
around with platters of whatever drugs
you want to take. I mean, that was Yeah.
Just it's just a different lifestyle
that these people are living and and and
what's sad is when you're around that,
you begin to think like this is normal.
Like everybody does this, don't they?
Don't they all do this? you know, and
and it's real easy to get sucked up into
that kind of a lifestyle just because
it's not so shocking when you hear about
it from there. It's also sad that you I
mean the law enforcement's probably got
to know. Mhm. Oh, they're probably those
things are going on. Yeah. Yeah. It
doesn't get, you know, enforced
properly. Yeah. You know, I mean, in in
this case, you know, he was shelling out
money all over the place. And so, you
know, I'm I'm sure at some level there
are some people that, you know, would
probably say something, but they know
the right people that pay them off and
they don't say anything. And then, you
know, I'm also surprised that so many
people around him was aware of this
abuse and nobody they didn't do
anything.
I mean, I mean, I look at a person like
this and I say, you know, that's
somebody's daughter. Mhm. I mean, that's
a child of God, you know, and it's like
the things that that she had to endure
are just awful. You wouldn't want you
wouldn't wish your worst enemy to go
through those things. I mean, even
thinking about Justin Bieber while he
was a kid. Now, there's no hard evidence
that anything happened to him, but the
videos you see of Diddy interacting with
Bieber on multiple occasions are really
sketchy. You have a 15-year-old and I'm
like I mean like hardly let him go to
somebody's house that I know really
well. Yeah. You know, it's like the I
can't believe that people would just
because of fame and fortune and and and
that's really what um I think drives
this underneath it. He gets away with
these kind of things because of
something that that that people want.
they want their child to be in the in
that spotlight or, you know, they're
hoping that that, you know, if you
become rich and famous, your life will
be, you know, free of problems. But,
man, some of these celebrities, I think,
are have a lifetime of abuse that they
that they can't even sleep at night.
They're constantly on drugs because of
what they've had to endure. You wonder
if the parents are thinking, you know,
there's a trickle down effect. You make
it, then I make it. you know, whatever
you make is going to spill down some to
me somehow. The love of money is the
root of all evil. You know, in Britney
Spears's um experience, I mean, I
remember watching as her court case cuz,
you know, she's kind of closer to my age
and and uh she was kind of rising to
fame when I was out there when when she
was there. And so I I I listened to a
couple of the court cases that she had
when she came out. And I mean, her
parents just absolutely would abuse her,
make her work for long hours, not let
her come home for vacations, and I mean,
that was just like the, you know, the
little monkey that would go and make
money for the family. It's just crazy.
Do you think he he had a connection to
God at one point?
I mean, it's hard to say. You don't you
don't know heart. And and this is why um
sometimes when you're looking on the
outside and you see these people that
are promoting God or they're saying, you
know, like, you know, hey um I want to
give all glory to God. It's very
confusing for a lot of people. And um I
just thought I'd play this for you. Um
this is pretty interesting that uh he
actually gives a lot of honor to God uh
for a lot of things. Listen to this.
Thank God cuz that that's that's my
secret weapon. It don't matter what
religion you are, but make sure you know
there's a higher power of love. And I
want to just say I give all glory to
God. Pray to God y'all get to do
something that you love for 30 years
consistently.
So interesting that he kind of ascribes
love to it. Yet this is like what
problem he I mean had was this this this
act that he was constantly subjecting
these people that were around him to was
not anything but the opposite of love. I
I think this also goes back to the idea
of the Bible is very balanced and yes it
does say call upon the name of the Lord
and you will be saved. But it also says
in Matthew 7 that there's many people
who will say,"Lord, did I do all these
things in your name?" And Jesus is like,
"I don't know you. Go away from me, you
lawless ones, right? Lawless." They're
not keeping the law. And the law is
what? It's transgression of of sin is a
transgression of the law. So they're
sinning. They're sinners. And there's a
balance between you can say I love
Jesus, but if you don't act out and show
that you love Jesus and show the fruits
of Jesus, but you keep sinning and not
fully surrendering to him and saying,
"Lord, take my heart. Change me." Then
that's not truly acknowledging Jesus
though with your words, but your acts
you're not. Yeah. I think there's an
assumption too built into what he's
saying and that is if there's something
that appears to be good that comes my
way all is definitely from
God. Maybe it's not. Mhm. The devil can
bless too. Maybe he's been given
something that you know Satan knew would
destroy him because you look at the
fruit of that. Look at where he's at
now.
You think God gave all that to him
knowing that but God says he's not going
to give it to you any more than you can
handle. Mhm. So he either could have
handled it or or it wasn't from God. I
mean you look at the free will and and
look how it just destroyed him. But also
look at the wake of your life. Like in
the wake of his life, how many
people were either having a better
existence or you know what I mean? It's
it it's like all these people that are
coming out. I mean, hundreds of people.
That's what's crazy to me. Hundred and
something um um Yeah. What do you call
them? Indictments or whatever. Like the
court cases that are drafted up against
him. Um that's a lot of people. And
those are the people that just step
forward. Yeah. And some of these people
are kids. Yeah. And so, you know, for
you to destroy all these people's lives
just so you can have a better existence
is so against the government of God.
Well, and it doesn't give God a very
good name if you're saying, "God gave me
all this and then you look at what you
did with it."
Yeah. I mean, so many people that will
use this as an argument against God.
Right. Exactly. I mean, Mahatma Gandhi
was one of the ones like, "I like your
Christ, but I I don't like your
Christians." Interesting. Right. And
Jesus says, you know, if you scandal one
of the little ones, it is better for you
to tie a rock around your neck and jump
off a bridge. Mhm. Yes. That's how bad
it is, right? And you just deliberately
use God's name and thank him for what
he's given to you even though, you know,
you're doing all these these things that
just go completely against his
character. If you could distill down
what is the Bible getting at or what is
God's government really all about? I
think Jesus summed it up so well. To
love God with all your heart, with all
your mind, with all your soul. That
means I'm listening to God and doing
what God wants me to do, right? and
loving my fellow man. It's like anybody
that comes into contact with me, how can
I bless you or help you or make your
life enriched by your interacting with
me? That's really what the Bible's all
about. And I think this is the part
where people get this like mixed up
because it's verbally said, "Oh, I
follow God or I give glory to God." But
then nothing in the life actually shows
that you care about another person. But
I want to read a couple verses to you. 1
Corinthians 6:18. Uh Felipe, go ahead
and read that. Flee from sexual
immorality. All other sins a person
commits are outside the body. But
whoever sins sexually sins against their
own body. What do you think about that?
It's pretty clear. I mean, whatever you
whatever sexual in reality that it means
a lot of things, right?
um you're sinning against yourself in
the process as well because other sins
killing lying
um stealing it affects other people but
sins that that are committed against
yourself as well are included in that
God is telling you is like hey love
yourself love your neighbor that's why
the commandments are there but it's
pretty clear you can sin against
yourself against your own body I think
it's very interesting that you have this
um this kind of example of somebody who
has completely like gone down a dark
path with their own sexuality and it
just gets worse and worse and worse and
the things that they have to do to keep
making that exciting is just worse and
worse and worse things and the Bible has
really good examples of that flee from
that I mean I think of Joseph right he
didn't stand there and toy with it and
think about it he ran away from the
experience that he was like, "Look, I
need to just get out of here." How many
of us do that today? How many of us
like, you know, uh have that kind of of
understanding that, you know, these
things can be damaging, very damaging to
our bodies. And it's not an uncommon sin
as well, right? Right? You know, studies
show that 76% or more of teenagers have
had encounter with, you know,
pornography or other
sexual sexual immoral sins as well
because pornography is a sin. Yeah.
Right. And of course, what happens in
Hollywood is a whole new level. But it's
that's not the only sexual immoral uh
immoral sin that you can commit as well.
It can be committed in the own privacy
of of your room. Yeah. And and you know,
it's amazing to me that that you can
have the same act in an a marriage and
out of a marriage and one of them is
going to be a blessing and one of them
is going to destroy your body. And that
to me is like, you know, God is is is
gifting us this beautiful thing that
should bring us closer together. And in
when in a marriage context, that's
really something that helps glue that
marriage together. And when it's outside
of that bounds of what God wants, um it
can be very destructive to people's
lives. What do you think about this
verse, Denique? But among you, there
must not be even a hint of sexual
immorality or of any kind of impurity or
of greed because these are improper for
God's holy people. What do you think
about that?
Yeah. I mean, shy away from all of the
sexual immorality, right? Right. Like
you guys were discussing, it's
destructive. And think God has created
um he's created sexual desires. He's
created even a desire to
procreate, but within marital bounds.
Um sex is something that is so bonding
with all the chemicals and everything
like that that God said, "Hey, basically
it's like a fire in a fireplace. It's
awesome and it's beautiful and it's
really something you can appreciate when
it's in the fireplace, but it's outside
of that, it'll burn your house down.
Yeah. And that's how I see this. It can
be very, very, very destructive. And I I
love it that it's like, look, God's
people, we need to get a handle on this.
There's a lot of verses that talk about,
you know, Paul was constantly kind of
trying to encourage the churches, hey,
don't be like this, you know, like
everyone else is is like this. Be
different. You're God's people. you
know, we should not have this particular
struggle. There's a picture of where
they came from, too. As Paul is writing
to the Ephesians, he's saying among you,
he's he's talking about that church.
There's a problem in the church. Yeah.
People that are claiming to be
Christians, like people that are wearing
crosses. Yeah. Right. Yeah. And what's
interesting is you look at their past
history, it wasn't just this. There was
a lot of stuff that went with that.
They're involved in witchcraft and
spirituality.
you know. Yep. I wonder how much of that
was was all together in their their
paganism essentially. It seems blending
it. Yeah. It seems like in paganism when
you kind of listen to what they had
going on, sexual morality was always
right there with it. the temple
prostitutes or you know and and and the
corons and all the people that were
around the Greeks and the Romans and
things and yeah I mean you you saw Rome
when it was at its peak it fell
apart largely probably fueled by the
sexual immorality of the day. So we're
kind of seeing those same sort of things
today and um I believe that that this is
great advice for us. If you want to do
what God wants you to do, guard well
this part of your body. This is not even
a hint. Not even a hint. I love it. Yes.
So true.
Heartbreak
Jacob and he for you
Israel. I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God. and he shall go out no
more. I will ride on him in the name of
my
God. Be strong in the Lord and in the
power shall you
[Music]
streng like heels.
alone, but by every word that proceeds
from the mouth of God.
What was it like when you were in
Hollywood? I mean, you you grew up a
Christian.
left that did you leave that completely
when you were in Hollywood did did you
kind of say I'm Christian but then what
in my own experience I think I became
completely selfish
I wanted the fame and the fortune and
the money and the girls and the cars and
everything else. Why? Because I wanted
it. I didn't care who I had to step on
to get to that place. And it really
truly made me a selfish person until
finally I was like coming to the grips
with like this is not a happy existence.
And uh right then God met me at the
right time and really um put my feet
back on a path to serve him. And I'll
tell you what, like it's a lot of people
always question like you guys are always
hammering Hollywood and why are you guys
always saying all this stuff about them?
Is because a majority of stuff that
comes out of Hollywood is not pushing
people to have a better relationship
with either people or God. A lot of it
is really just eroding away at what God
has designed for us in this world. What
was your breaking point? My breaking
point was was was really kind of coming
to the to the place of saying, I'm tired
of being selfish. And um you know, God,
show me who you are. I really, you know,
I I remember running under that
Hollywood sign and praying to God one
day and just saying, you know what, God,
I want to see you. I want to see I want
to see you work in my life. And God just
showed up time and time and time again.
And I came to the position that it was
like, I cannot serve two masters. I
can't be in this world promoting myself
and trying to get myself in the higher
positions and live according to the way
that God was telling me to live in the
Bible. See, I think that's the beauty of
God is that God says, "I've got a plan
for everybody. He has a plan for Diddy."
Yeah. I mean, I hope that by him falling
this far in prison someday, he will
think about God, like really think about
God and not and just be like, "Lord, I I
called on your name. I acknowledge you,
but I did all of these things. Now, help
me to really see you, like you said,
under the Hollywood sign for who you
are, and help me to truly surrender my
life of sin to you so you can transform
my heart." I hope that happens. Wouldn't
that be amazing if you saw somebody this
depraved? Mhm. Turn around, give his
heart to God, and completely be
transformed, what would that do for the
gospel? And we know of Satanists that
have transformed, you know? Exactly. I
know this person is is is going to go
through a rough ride. And what's really
sad is I hope that he doesn't just all
of a sudden swing it to so much
confusion about what happened that none
of it comes up and is like asking for
forgiveness. I want to show you though.
Um, here's another clip that he is
talking about God. I want to hear your
thoughts on this. Just got that call one
day from God and she was like, "It's
it's time." Her voice sounds way better
than that though, more godly though. But
it was God as a woman. So she was like,
"It's time." And I was like, "It's
time."
The reason he made this album was he
basically says God showed up. She told
him. What do you think about that?
Doesn't sound biblical. Doesn't sound
biblical, right? No, it certainly does
not. Same. If it if it speaks not
according to the law or to the testimony
or to what the Bible
describes, you got to question where's
this coming from? Sounds like Ariana
Grande. Yeah. You know what I mean?
Yeah. Yeah. And and and it's just
confusion. I mean, this is this is the
part where where where I think a lot of
people who who don't have a relationship
with God, they see religion on this
surface level like this. And you know, I
I I hope if he's at all had any kind of
exposure to religion, I mean, somebody
give this guy a Bible in prison. Give
him a Bible. It's got nothing to do but
sit there and read, you know, and I hope
that he actually starts to listen. This
was one of P. Diddy's um um producers
and he actually ended up spending the
night at Diddy's house and they were
working on some things. You can see the
whole interview. It's quite interesting
and eye opening. Um I'm just going to
show you a part of this interview, but
um he saw there was some very satanic
things that were going on in that part
of the music industry and um it freaked
him out and in fact he kind of started
making um like gospel style music and he
came to a interesting conclusion simply
about what gospel music was really
battling with. Listen to this. I think
that Satan's grip on
music, it it's not just
uh genres that are not necessarily
Christian or gospel. I think they all
bottleneck into Satan. Um, and I think
that the gatekeepers in one are the same
as the gatekeepers in another. There
there's certain rituals you have to do
if you want to get to the top of the
industry. I used to ask
God, Lord, how come? Because I love the
sound of of
R&B. You know, I know that the lyrics
definitely don't honor God, but one of
my struggles was I can create that music
on a high level. Like, I love it. If I
get in the room and I get my gear, I can
create stuff that that the world would
like, right? So, I used to ask God, "How
come we I can't take
this and make this glorify you? How come
I can't take that sound and make it
glorify you?" Which a lot of guys do.
They take R&B and they'll put gospel
lyrics on top of it and just say it's
gospel. And the
Lord the Lord spoke to me and
said whenever the spirit of God is made
manifest in a
[Music]
room, the sound that is produced is not
that David would make sounds. He would
make sounds that would make demons leave
Saul. Yes. He would produce and he
wasn't singing on them. He would just
play the sound and the demons that used
to possess and harass Saul would depart
from him. So that means that there's a
sound that draws spirits. There is a
sound or repel spirits. Yes. It's not
just rebuking with your mouth. You can
rebuke a demon with the right sound.
Yes. And so it's time, I guess, for the
church to stop borrowing their sound.
Absolutely. From the world and start
getting into the Holy Spirit. Yes. Hear
the sounds that he's making so that
those sounds can have a distinction that
can deal with the atmospheres that are
going on in America.
Crazy, huh? This is This was Diddy's
producer. That was a producer that
helped Diddy make some songs for his
album. Wow, dude. The rocks are speaking
out. Uhhuh. Right. The the rocks are
crying out. I found that really
interesting. I mean, when you watch this
guy's whole interview, it's fascinating.
I mean, he said he saw things there that
that basically made him believe in God
because of the darkness that he saw, but
he was recognizing and then having this
conversation with God and going, "Look,
just because you put Christian words on
it does not Christianize this thing."
Yeah, it makes perfect sense. I like
what he said about David and Saul. And I
was like, it's a good point. It's a good
point. You know what I mean? He kept
saying if there if there are um there's
songs that can that took the demons out
of soul, there's songs that take the
demons out of you. Does that mean that
there are songs that can bring the
demons into your home as well? That was
But I took from that. Yeah. Well, and
then thinking of Diddy was all about
hiphop and RBNB and stuff like that,
right?
So, if this is true, if this is
accurate, could could it be that, you
know, the music he was producing, which
was basically his whole life work, was
inviting demons in his life? It could be
something to think about. You know, I
think um we've played that clip from
Kanye West before where he was talking
with David Letterman and uh when he was
describing to David Letterman what he
does differently for his Sunday service
thing that he was doing. Um he was
removing certain instruments and certain
sounds because he said that's not
appropriate in a worship ceremony. And
so, you know, I mean, there are
musicians that understand the complexity
of sounds and what that does to your
bodies. the 808s, the low frequencies,
the hard-hitting sounds, and and and
there's a reason why those would not be
appropriate in these particular settings
if you really want to invite God or the
Holy Spirit into this. So, something to
think about. Listen to what Colossians
3:5 says. Keith, go ahead and read this.
Put to death, therefore, whatever
belongs to your earthly nature, sexual
immorality, impurity, lust, evil
desires, and greed, which is idolatry.
You think about how many things in the
music industry happen or are allowed to
happen because they they they understand
if I go down this road I'll get a lot of
money as greed. Greed drives a lot of
things. But I love how it's like put to
death. Mhm. Well, well, if you're
putting those things to death that are
destroying you and and if you see them
keep popping back up and alive, they're
obviously not going to die.
So, you need to take a lesson from this
and put it to death daily. Talk to God
daily. If you're struggling with sexual
immorality, ask God daily. Put this to
death today. Put this to death today.
Because the Bible says that even if you
don't commit a sin, if you are
supporting or watching or enjoying
somebody who commits those sins, you are
also guilty of that sin. The language
Paul uses there is take pleasure in them
that do those things as well. Romans
1:32. Go check that verse out. Um 1
Thessalonians 4 3-5 says it it is God's
will that you should be sanctified and
that you should avoid sexual immorality.
That each of you should learn how to
control your own body in a way that is
holy and honorable. Not in the
passionate lusts like the pagans who
don't know
God. If we were to go back in time and
look at some of
the music festivals of the ancient pagan
days, I think you would see a very
similar thing for us today. Absolutely.
It would look like the things that we
have today. These two things go hand in
hand. And why the music with the sexual
lusts, those things prey upon our anim
animalistic tendencies and our lower
passions get fed and you feed the you
feed the flesh. The the pagans had full
temple prostitutes that were having
sexual orgies on stage. I mean, I
remember when I was a teenager and I got
into watching MTV and I'm pretty sure I
saw it live, that kiss between Britney
Spears and Madonna and Christina
Aguilera and I was shocked to the bones
cuz I was like 12. Yes. I'd never
witnessed anything like that before. I
know. But they do it on purpose. I mean,
Madonna says that she will do these
things to make people more aware, more
comfortable with the LGBTQ agenda. There
is an agenda and if you just keep
putting it out there, people will feel
sympathetic towards it and then it won't
be alarming. But when you do that on
stage, you are copying what the pagans
were doing in their worship services.
And then the question is who then do you
worship Satan? Satan when he came to
Jesus in Matthew 4, he offered him the
whole world. He's like bow down to me.
I'll give you the whole world. How many
of these people, these celebrities are
given the same thing? And I'm not making
a blanket statement like all of these
celebrities openly or closed in at home
worship Satan. I'm not saying that. But
I do believe that when you want to get
to the top that there's a price to pay
whether you know it or not, there is a
price to pay. It does not I do not
believe that this kind of thing with
this kind of immorality is a gift from
God. Like Diddy was saying earlier like
God put me here. That's not from God.
God God has a lifestyle in mind like
when you came out of Hollywood when you
left this all behind you left behind
probably money right because there's a
lot more money you made in Hollywood
than working in ministry and fame and
and I and all these things but the joy
of being in God's
house and I'm sure you can confirm this
is so much greater than to be in tinsel
town trying to make make it to fame.
That's why I think God says, "Taste and
test that the Lord is good." You know, I
tested these worldly things. I tested
the partying. I tested the the the
money. I tested all these things that I
thought was going to bring me happiness.
And at the end of the road, it was
unfulfilling. End of the day,
unfulfilling. And and even if you gain a
little bit of of, you know, um of
success in that area, there's always
another ladder to climb. And there's
always somebody who has more than you
and somebody that's got better stuff
than you and there's no end to that.
Whereas like I'm telling you when you
just give God a chance like Lord teach
me how you want me to live and it's like
it's it's a peace that passes all
understanding. It's a it's a joy in
different things. Like now I get
enjoyment out of just my relationships,
my people. Not thinking what can I get
out of these different people and you
know if I get to know this person, how
can I move up the ladder? I mean, it's
just like a constant, you know, selfish,
self-focused view. And when I moved away
from that, I feel like like life has
just got a whole another flavor now.
Mhm. So, why why did you go into
Hollywood? What was like your your
background in all of this? What
happened? Um, what drew me to Hollywood
was was really uh uh I didn't quite know
what I wanted to do for a living. And
when I went to college, um, I was taking
some some different classes that they
were offering. And that first kind of
week, they give you like a bunch of
booths at at a at a, you know, you can
kind of pick the different classes that
you want to get involved in. And they
had a film studies class. And so, um, I
decided to take the film studies. I
liked making little videos and movies
with my brother, um, from a childhood
on. And um I didn't consider it as a
possible career choice, but once I
started taking these classes um we were
up there in in sort of Northern
California um and this particular
teacher, his brother was famous and he
had some connections with Hollywood and
worked on some major movies. So he took
this core little class of about 30 kids
and we went and um watched some movies
being created and that when I walked on
to the first movie set I ever walked on
um it was some movie called The Sphere
and it was with Sharon Stone and Dustin
Hoffman and I just was like, "Oh wow,
this is amazing." Like these people are
getting paid for this. I want to do
that. And uh throughout that year, the
teacher, you know, he kind of came from
Hollywood. but he'd worked on
Schindler's List. He'd worked on a bunch
of movies that were were quite known.
And so he said, you know, um it's not
really going to matter if you graduate
from this little tiny liberal arts co
college. You're going to go to Hollywood
and start at the bottom. And so I kind
of was just like, well, why am I racking
up a school bill if it doesn't matter?
And if I want to go and do this, why
don't I just go and do it? And that's
why I just pulled out of school and went
down to Hollywood and jumped into it.
and I only knew one person in Hollywood.
So, I went and visited her and stayed
with her for a weekend. And um she was
an actress, still is an actress today.
So, she had um lived in Beverly Hills at
the time that I went and visited her and
and to me when I saw people treating her
like that, I just was like, "Okay,
that's actually what I want to do. I
want to be in front of the camera." You
did acting, right? A little bit. Uh
yeah, actually. Um I I just being there
that weekend with her. She had a meeting
with her manager. her manager worked um
a lot with Steven Spielberg. His name
was um Richard Glasser and um so I I
went and met with him and he took me on
in the very beginning and put me in go
to these acting classes, do this and
that's what kind of like began. But I
was a terrible actor. I was awful. And
so I just never ever really kind of
booked anything that would have brought
me up to the next level. And and about
six years into that, I was I was kind of
disenfranchised with the in front of the
camera stuff. And we we'd work behind
the camera on various different things
just just to get around it. But never
really could book anything more than a
commercial.
Scotty, would you trade after the all
this experience you had in Hollywood, 10
years there, right? Would you trade your
life right now to go back there?
Absolutely not. And in fact, I wouldn't
hesitate to do it this way again. I
would have come out and doesn't matter
how much how much you know success I I I
would have been given or whatever um I
tell you it does not compare to serving
God and the satisfaction and and the the
joy I mean it's been a hard road trust
me you know you you probably could have
an easier life doing something else but
just the idea of leading somebody to a
relationship with God is so much like
like that's that's the best payment
anyone could ever have and God has been
faithful. I had one kind of just um you
know request of God when I came out. I
said, you know, God, I've always been
able to take care of things in life and
uh I want to have a family and um please
just just give me the basics of life and
I'll be happy and I'll serve you with
all my heart. And I'll tell you what, I
haven't starved and I've had food in my
fridge and I've had what I've needed.
And uh I truly feel that um this life of
this path with God is 100 million times
better than anything that I think I
could have ever experienced. So So you
see all these celebrities, you see Diddy
partying, um doing the freakoffs, doing
the drugs, doing the drinking, they've
got the money, they've got the fame.
Now, you weren't like an A-list
celebrity, but you were surrounded by
some of these celebrities like you
mentioned, like Britney Spears and
Justin Timberlake, and I know your
brother worked in Hollywood, too, and
met some people like on that level. Um,
but having lived somewhat of that
lifestyle of drugs and and obviously,
you know, in Hollywood, you can work or
work earn way more money than you would
ever in in doing ministry. What you
don't see is what's going on in the
heart of these celebrities when they
live this lifestyle. So when you did
that, was it fulfilling right after you
like, "Oh man, I had a great night. You
know, I did all this." Or is it like
something else? to be honest like you
know people often talk about the
sacrifice that you make to follow God
and and that there is a big sacrifice of
worldly you know pleasures or whatever
like this to to live a lifestyle that's
like God but there's actually a
sacrifice on both sides of that fence.
Those people as you see with Diddy and
this situation that he's gotten into,
they're paying a price, a very hard
price. And it's in fact a much harder
yoke just like what the Bible says,
"Take my yoke upon you that you know
your burdens will be light like going
God's way is a billion times lighter
than what the devil will inflict upon
you." And so yeah, it's like um you
know, I think that people have this
false sense of like, "Yeah, that was
fun, but you're empty, right?" I mean,
Shila Labou constantly said, "I have
this god-sized hole that I'm trying to
fill and I can't fill it." And the more
that I like consume, I can't fill it. It
seems like it's getting bigger. That's a
lot of people's experience. Friend of
mine when I was there in Los Angeles, um
uh he was starting to book commercials
and there was a couple people that I
would hang out with that um had some
success and um um one of the the the
kids um he just had a a streak of
booking things and getting like a lot of
neat parts and commercials and all sorts
of stuff. and he had this house in
Beverly Hills and um he seemed happy to
me. I mean, what I would have appeared
to to be, he has everything that he
needs. And uh he committed suicide after
um a couple times of hanging out with
him. And um he didn't at all say he was
hurting or anything. And I think that
really struck me when I was there is
just like, you know, here's somebody
that like I never said anything to. I
mean, I grew up as a Christian. and I
had all this understanding of of of this
war between Christ and Satan and you
know he shared with me his Buddhist
faith and I just kind of in the back of
my mind was like yeah that's not right
but you know didn't say anything about
it and I could have said something to
him and I didn't I didn't even know he
was hurting and you know it's like uh
coming back into a relationship with God
I think that's that's something that's
really stuck with me and I said you know
I would like to be bold and and not hide
my light anymore. I want to like, you
know, be bold with sharing God because
with anybody cuz, you know, you never
know if people are searching or what.
You you you don't have to dig very deep
and I'm sure this is going to come out a
bunch in the in this diddy case, but
what looks from the outside as like
glamorous life. I mean, it's full of
pain. It's full of misery. It's full of
like slavery basically. And and a lot of
people have are going to have lifelong
problems sleeping at night, you know,
fear of being around crowds, like
whatever is coming out of this from all
these people that have have done this.
And and that's why I say like taste and
test and see that the Lord is good. Like
give God a chance. Just say, "Hey, look
God, I'm going to do 10 days. I'm going
give you 10 days not listening to that
worldly music. I'm going to just, you
know, I'm going to do what you want me
to do. I'm going to eat healthy. I'm
going to take walks outside in nature.
I'm going listen to the birds and see
the beautiful nature that you built. And
I guarantee you, you'll walk away from
those 10 days going, "There's something
wonderful about the way that God wants
us to live." Yeah. And you can do that.
You haven't gone so far where you feel
like you can't. I know. Like I read a
quote from George Clooney over the last
couple years and it said he said
something like, "I just wish I could go
out of my house and take a walk in
Central Park without being recognized."
Yeah. Once you turn it on, there's no
off button. Like I don't think you can
just be like, "Okay, nobody know who I
am anymore." Yeah. Like
like like sometimes we get recognized
occasionally and it's nice like, "Oh,
thank you for watching." Yeah. But I can
easily go to Walmart and be in and out
and nobody knows who I am and it's
great. That's a nice freeing feeling. It
is. It's a totally different being
recognized. Yeah, that's too. It's not
like someone's chasing you down the road
and like ah like you know it's like hey
I watch your videos you know that's
cool. You don't have people following
you around with cameras video cameras
you know spying on you seeing what
you're doing writing about it later you
know you took a walk in the park. Yeah.
Some of these celebrities have had to
get restraining orders against people.
So I mean as much as you would think
that that would be fun just dig around
in any sort of celebrity that's talked
about what life is like after they got
famous. And I I think the most people
would be like, "Yeah, no thanks. I don't
want that." You can't even do normal
things in life anymore. Like I can't
imagine seeing Taylor Swift. I mean,
there's people waiting outside of her
New York City apartment. Yeah. She can't
go grocery shopping. Yeah, you can't.
You can't do that. Like, oh, I just
can't imagine living that way. And it's
actually lonely. Um, you know, you hear
enough of people that have gotten
success on on a on a really high level,
even if it's in business su business
success. Um, they describe it as a very
lonely feeling. Have you and you've
talked to some celebrities when you were
there like A-list celebrities. What do
they tell you? Did they say anything
like that? Like, hey, I'm I'm like this
is not cool or you know, I don't
remember having any conversations like
that that people were just like, you
know, very open and honest. But the few
people that I did know that were kind of
like, you know, getting some success,
um, you know, they talk about the
challenges that it that it proposed and
and, you know, it's like, yeah, it's
difficult just to go to the grocery
store and and you know, some people
thrive off of that and then you see like
day in and day out like, you know,
you've seen Justin Bieber videos where
he's just, you know, getting mad at the
paparazzi and trying to shove them out
of the I mean, they just they just will
enter into your life and there's nothing
you can do about it. So, it makes me
wonder though, those people who are kind
of up and coming but weren't A-list yet
that you met, why do they keep going? If
they were like, "Oh, it's hard." Why
would you keep going? Love of money.
Yeah, it's the love of money. And I
think that that um you know, you you're
attracted to that business to be a
creative in the first place and and you
know, they like the idea of having
something that they're influencing
everybody. That's what really artists
are, right? you're an influencer. You're
not making a painting that doesn't
influence anybody. And and people like
the recognition. They want to be
appreciated by other people. But you
really set yourself up to be a god, you
know, that's being worshiped. Mhm. In in
my case, I think I didn't get that as a
child, that validation. And, you know, I
think there was a hole in my life
seeking out that validation from other
people. And I think that's what if I
were to be honest, that's what really
drew me to it. And um it's funny because
God had to reorientate me and sort of
like refocus me on not needing that and
my validation is coming from God. And
it's and it's like funny having a a you
know a actual public persona now that we
do this channel and we do this show and
stuff like this because it's like the
more we we've kind of grown the less I
actually like the spotlight and I don't
really care to have that light you know
shining on me and it's like I I I enjoy
much more having a a group discussion
and stuff. So, and whether you like it
or not, by beholding, you become change.
By beholding celebrities, by beholding
the movies, the the the music industry,
all of that, you become change. And you
want to get that recognition yourself.
Yeah. Right. When in reality, we should
be looking at, for example, Joseph when
the temptation came with potterer's
wife. He's like, "Wait, no. How could I
ever sin against my God?" Yeah. He was
not looking for for Piper's uh approval
or for his wife's approval. He wanted
God's approval. It's because when he
went to Egypt, he was probably vocal or
people knew or saw how he worshiped God
and they knew that he was a follower of
God. So if he does something that messes
up like that, what's that going to do to
people's belief in God? And I think
that's something we all need to think
about, right? We are representatives of
God. What we do will have an influence
on other people. And so, you know,
sometimes we are the worst damage to the
Christian faith. I mean, a lot of people
will point their fingers and say
Christians are no different than the
worldly people. And and you know, I
mean, there's a reason for that. I think
that Satan is aiming his attack on the
Christians. Is most of his desires is to
try and lead people away from God. And
if you pick the the person that's that's
influential to the sheep, then you're
going to get a lot of them. So, you
know, there's a reason why I think that
that sometimes the the people who have
been given a higher position or whatever
get targeted by Satan, but we need to
pray for our leaders. And I think that's
why we really honestly when you see a
pastor or you see somebody that's out
there um you know doing ministry or
something like that, pray for them.
There's a large attack that's coming at
them. Yeah. So, all right, let's
uh read a read one more. Keith, go ahead
and read this. The acts of the flesh are
obvious. Sexual immorality, impurity and
debauchery, idolatry and witchcraft,
hatred, discord, jealousy, fits of rage,
selfish ambition, dissensions, factions,
and envy, drunkenness, orgies, and the
like. I warn you, as I did before, that
those who live like this will not
inherit the kingdom of God. Let that be
a stark warning to anybody that has kind
of a tainted view of what the Hollywood
lifestyle is like. When you see them
partying and you see them doing all
these things, you go, "Wow, that looks
like fun." There's something better
coming, guys. Don't Don't set your
sights on this world. This world is
already on its way out. And there is
something that is beautiful that is
coming. and and and if you truly want to
inherit the kingdom of God, just take
what you're involved in, whether you're
watching something, whether you're
you're paying attention to a particular
celebrity, do they fit into this model?
Do they actually promote godliness or
cleanliness or, you know, being holy and
righteous and pure? I mean, those are
the things that that person is
promoting. Or are they promoting things
that are opposite than that? And if they
are, it would be better to avoid some of
those things. But I don't want to leave
you with that. I want to leave you with
this. Proverbs 28:13 says, "Whoever
conceals his transgressions will not
prosper, but he who confesses and
forsakes them will obtain mercy." Amen.
And the reason why I I I think it would
be amazing if Diddy caught a glimpse of
this. Mhm. He realized I did things that
were wrong and I'm sorry and apologized
and poured his heart out to God. The
this promise is the same for P. Diddy as
it is for you and me today. God will
have mercy upon you. Amen. Don't hide
him. If you if you in your own life or
whatever, if you come up to a place that
like, hey, whatever you've done wrong is
now brought to light, ask for
forgiveness and you will obtain mercy.
First John 1:9 says, "If we've confess
our sins, he," meaning God is faithful
and just to forgive us of our sins and
to cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
If we have a lifestyle that is
unrighteous or things that we know would
not please God, the Bible's telling us
just confess them to God and he is able
to cleanse us from those things. And
that includes Pitti as far as he might
have gone into all the stuff that he's
practiced, you know. That's right. The
same the same offer is extended to him.
Mhm. That's right. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comment
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]